what's up reject nation I'm Greg I'm
John if we look tired of [ __ ] cuz we
really are in game tickets we have been
trying since 4:50 a.m. we woke up at
that time to get our Avengers endgame
tickets and just like Star Wars or
infinity war the sites are all crashing
every single time we're at the checkout
like we got the seats let's try to check
out not panning out well for us and I
was like I know this has been out for a
while but since it's not letting us
login those are text messages of you
know my girlfriend mm but yeah and
you're trying to get tickets right now
so it's it's not panning out well we're
really trying to get our tickets we're
just trying to get anything at this
point
every time we're like oh my god what
keeps logging me out is have no around
any oh my I'll watch this TV spot and
maybe get a little bit of a rest and
then we'll try again cuz it's been 45
straight minutes of this off of two
hours of sleep let's go for it
we do this we'd be going in short-handed
because he killed all that friend
we owe this look how good I look so we
know it was there in the sky
[Music]
first Avengers yeah location okay snaps
[Music]
yeah we know we freaking know oh man
dude higher man Thor and Captain America
just walking towards them
yeah man who knew the backs of legs can
be like what I mean just like this this
trailer makes so much out of so many
simple moments like yeah at that moment
where they're all standing together you
know Tony and cap and the ant-man and
everybody oh yeah the whole crew there
Ronan is that thing that people get mad
about and like during the reaction it's
funny how they do so much trigger
manipulation that we're like yeah we
manipulate them the last time it was
Thor's hammer
no now it's definitely Stormbreaker when
he captures it from the front of Captain
Marvel at that particular moment yeah
yeah I'm sure I just have come to expect
that nothing in these trailers exactly
but it's so cool because you do have
Tony and cap like interacting with each
other so yeah I mean like we knew they
were gonna reunite bit and it seems it's
hard for me to believe this is just pure
trailer manipulated footage but you know
we had that those shots where there was
Captain America war machine and you know
like Widow and it's like oh and that's
that must be Tony and nebula returning
because the way the location looks and
everything it's hard for me to go oh
it's all it's further manipulation yeah
yeah hey I guess we get verified you
know Tony makes it back to earth and
reunites with Pepper Potts so maybe he
gets to deliver her his Iron Man mask
just directly yeah and then when you
have the moment to where they do have
Tony and Kat looking each other in the
shake hands that has that looks like
that's from Avengers Assemble at least
in that moment that we saw from those
set photos really go back to that the
picture of spider-man just to rub it in
all of our you know
tender wounds all right there's a little
job cut there because refresh the page
to see if there was anything available
on the site anyway let's just watch his
spot again
[Music]
look at this pump of mob action most
all those tats
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
back to me
[Music]
do you trust me I do last time they had
a civil war they did yeah it's some big
rebuilding of trust you know we've done
a full breakdown of the first trailer we
did a full breakdown of the second
trailer and I'm sure we could do it for
this one
but Aang I'm very sleepy and I'm trying
to get the tickets and be reading into a
lot of just singular shot yeah
succinct and deliberate teeth yeah man
pretty cool though certainly gets you
hyped well everyone's Facebook cover for
you they're gonna be these backs of legs
we're gonna try to get these tickets
guys thanks for being here this is an
awesome trailer no idea how stressed I
am that's our try to get these damn
tickets subscribe click that
notification Val I'll talk to you